[Music]
hey there river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
the Sweetwater secrets preview for the
Riverdale finale chapter 35 brave new
world aka our very last preview episode
for season 2 I'm not gonna cry not
you're not gonna cry now are you alright
I know we're all still reeling over that
devastating jughead cliffhanger from
last week's penultimate episode and the
fact that pretty much everyone in
Riverdale can add murderer to their
resume I only miss when I mean to is
that under special skills yeah maybe but
based off of the promo for brave new
world
it seems that life in Riverdale is only
going to get more intense but let's
switch gears into something a little
more fun now as you River babes know I
think it is a real treat to read through
all of your hisses and kisses from the
last episode but since this is our last
preview episode together of season two I
wanted to do something extra special for
you now when I caught up with the
Riverdale cast at PaleyFest it was the
day after they had all wrapped season
two so back when the emotions were fresh
and the feelings were raw so here's
everything they had to tell me about
this final episode
take a look you guys have just wrapped
season two what was that like what was
the vibe on set in that final day it was
good I mean it's it I think it's 50%
relief that we we got through it all and
then 50% just pure joy I'm still soaking
it up you know like it hasn't quite hit
me yet but but yeah what was your
reaction when you read the season 2
finale I knew kind of what was going on
a little bit and I could have had a fair
idea I don't usually talk to any of
these guys about it I just keep it to
myself I wasn't that surprised actually
the fans are gonna be very surprised
well I have to say that we leave Alice
Cooper in a
very interesting predicaments
interesting season three fingers crossed
well well I think it would be really fun
new adventure for her if it bleeds it
leads what happens in the in the finale
there's so much that comes like to a
head
you know the north side and the south
side they're really going at it you know
the lodges and the Andrews with the
whole mayoral race and everything
basically what you think you know you
don't lose your reaction when you read
that season two finale script all the
fields all the field that feels romantic
feels intense romantic sad I mean it's
kind of like how it was last season in a
way like very emotional at the end which
is good for us it's not just like some
big cliffhanger well it is but you know
but there's there's still a little bit
of resolved with the characters and a
little bit of emotional I don't know
what I'm saying I'm I got like two hours
of sleep you got it look amazing I'm
bearing with you girl I love Lily's
honesty and I love that she said that
she felt all the feels now I'm keeping
my fingers crossed that that means juggy
will be okay I don't know but which
riverdale stars teases left you the most
tantalized for the finale shout it out
in the comments below but now let's take
a look at the finale promo for brave new
world now I held my breath for the
entire thing but I will say that this
part had me shook our story's not over
it's just beginning
this made me scream and this moment made
my heart pound
once and for all
I can't really tell you much it more
about the finale because pretty much
everything is a spoiler at this point so
instead I'll let Madelaine Petch and
give you guys a show knee teeth okay you
tease about Sheryl and Tony's
relationship these final few episodes a
lot of like big relationship things
happen for like Cheryl Tony I feel like
there's a couple like big relationship
steps that they take which I love I'm
excited for how to describe it a union
of some sort yeah they like find a way
to bond over something new which i think
is very exciting and ultimately it's
like growing to be a very strong
relationship which is I think very
unusual yeah yeah and it's like really
they don't like that's the one thing is
like I was always wondering when it
first started like is the Josie thing
gonna break them up and then she found
out and she's still love Cheryl through
it and I was like wow they have no
secrets like this is the oh I think the
only way ship in riverdale who has
really been truly based on the truth
mm-hmm which is a great foundation with
a really good job very good stuff but of
course I will be offering you guys my
traditional three clues but be warned
they're extra tricky this week here we
go
all right number one an underdog will
try to seal the political spotlight but
they could be barking up the wrong tree
number two speaking of barking a beloved
Archie comics character makes an
adorable return I love Archie in the
whole game and number three someone will
fall off the wagon
another will jump on the bandwagon and a
life-changing deal is made and with that
I'm going to send you all off into
finale land now be sure to check with me
right after you watch episode 22 chapter
35 brave new world for exclusive answers
from some surprise Riverdale stars about
the finale episodes biggest moments but
for now please give this video a like
and then hit the comments or chat with
me on Twitter to make your predictions
for what's gonna happen in the season 2
finale of Riverdale let's see if you can
try and decode my three clues I'll see
you after the finale River babes kisses
[Music]